uh the pentagon as you see is holding a
press conference right now to try to
unwind and define the chaos in
afghanistan if that is indeed possible
we've all been horrified by what we're
seeing meanwhile the uh
kabul airport is back up and running
three thousand troops are heading there
right now i think it should be as high
as seven uh it's another disaster in
afghanistan anyone who says anything
differently is flat out lying but
president biden is refusing to back down
he's trying to justify his decision that
allowed these chaotic scenes to take
place
i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement afghanistan now
was the right decision
and the president who promised to not
blame others is pointing his finger at
everyone but himself
when i came into office
i inherited a deal that president trump
negotiated with the taliban
under his agreement u.s forces would be
out of afghanistan by may 1
2021
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
it kind of makes sense if that was in
fact the facts but that's not the facts
the catastrophe in afghanistan is being
compared to the humiliating fall of
saigon during the end of the vietnam war
in 1975. remember we pulled out and
technically in 73 the secretary of state
dismissing such comparisons
this is not saigon we went to
afghanistan 20 years ago with one
mission and that mission was to deal
with the folks who attacked us on 9 11
and we have succeeded in that mission
but take a look at these two photos
getting a lot of attention on twitter
and should maybe even on instagram and
snapchat the left showing the scene in
vietnam back in 1975 you saw what the
other side showed the right show in
kabul in afghanistan today many people
are saying this
that uh saigon was a lot better than
what we're witnessing now because this
isn't quite over and what we've seen
right now is quite horrific the
president united states too is immense
credit i believe that was the first
speech he gave maybe ever that he truly
believes i think everything he said he
would have said 15 years ago or 20 years
ago don't tell me he got old don't tell
me someone loaded up the prompter that's
exactly what he believes if you read
general mattis's book if you read
general mcchrystal's book if you hear
about any interaction that joe biden has
had on the war on terror this is exactly
what he thinks we got to pull out of
afghanistan we better not kill bin laden
we can go over the horizon with all this
defense apparatus it didn't work the
choices he gave were flat out wrong
though when he came out and said the
choice was to put tens of thousands of
troops back in or pull out according to
the agreement in place he's not being
candid that is not the choice that he
had to say al qaeda was not a threat and
not in that region is not right it's to
say the war on terror moved on is not
correct the facts are differently and
dana uh the speech went on for 20
minutes like i said i really felt he
meant every word of it uh but sadly we
are suffering the consequences of this
that are going to hurt our reputation
our national security
uh for generations well we do know that
he
went explicitly against the advice of
the intelligence community the
department of defense um the state
department and all of the foreign policy
establishment which has been very much
in joe biden's camp except for really on
this issue they haven't they barely give
him any a hard time they hated trump
they couldn't wait for the community
they do and i do want to say one thing
about the um well i want to say one
thing about the trump comparison and the
blame there because i think it was
absolutely misplaced but i do think that
the speech in some ways if you are
giving a speech about when to leave and
why to leave
okay fine he like explains it but that
wasn't the topic today that wasn't the
failure to speak for the last six days
that was it was about the how
they decided on april 14th that they
were going to leave so i just assumed
that you didn't have to nag them and say
okay but you're working on the visas
right and you've got to plan for the
troops to get out right and you're not
going to do it in the middle of the
fighting season right you're gonna wait
to the winter like i didn't think that i
had to nag
somebody like the president of the
united states because after all as he
told us several times he's the most
experienced person in foreign policy
that the
u.s presidency has ever seen to the
point that he blames president trump
he's very curious as you all know we
talk about all the time he spends every
day reversing trump's decisions
sometimes knowing that it is illegal to
do so and consulting constitutional
scholars so if that's the case why then
does he not accept the president's deal
in terms of getting out of the iran
nuclear agreement
because the same argument could be made
i mean if you are bound by this
agreement with the taliban of all people
that was one thing when president trump
said that we would get out and i'm not
saying it would have been better i don't
i don't you don't know but here's the
thing president trump's
plan was it would be conditions based
and the taliban is the one that broke
the conditions which means that to me if
you're in an agreement with somebody
and they break the contract that means
that you you don't have to be involved
in that contract anymore um i have a lot
more to say but i'll just one other
thing
the afghan security forces have lost
tens of thousands of
of fighters some people said 70 now they
were able to get to a stalemate again
not good enough they're not going to be
a democracy okay we get it but the air
power that we were providing is what was
keeping that at a stalemate it was
president biden that decided to end that
in the middle of the fighting season
when he knew that they were ready to
roll on in there so to me the criticism
against president trump is galling
i do think the president believes this i
can just mention one thing he leaves
camp david after not speaking for six
days to come to the white house to give
a speech for 20 minutes saying get back
on a helicopter to go back to camp day
but as if like there's nothing else to
do here
it's it's astounding he's got a vacation
to enjoy i hear they have a great golf
course um kennedy when you look at this
it doesn't really matter i think there
was a very important point that dana
brought up there's two different issues
should we say should we not stay and
then how did you do it how did you
execute the dismount please tell me this
isn't one of the most embarrassing
humiliating things that you've ever
witnessed that america is a part of yeah
and that's that's a huge intelligence
failure if they didn't know this was
going to happen because literally anyone
who had been involved in afghanistan
whether they were advising or people who
fought there people who lost limbs and
lost people they were fighting against
side by side they all knew that this was
going to happen so joe biden made the
assertion today that he knows more about
afghanistan than anyone that he has been
in this in one way or another for so
long then how come he didn't know this
and then he talked about how you know
the taliban doesn't have an air force uh
but the security forces that we train
they have an air force like well guess
who has an air force now the taliban
does guess who has all these weapons and
perhaps all this intelligence the
taliban does and for people who have
been saying for a long long time maybe
we should learn the lessons of vietnam
so we don't have another saigon this is
what happened sometimes getting out is
just as dangerous as getting in and
staying in a protracted fruitless
unwittable situation for two decades
kennedy i would add this the contractors
volunteered to stay
and the mechanics and the instructors so
you would you said okay you guys follow
the air we'll be able to fix it we'll be
able to coach you the contractor's there
so you keep writing the checks we'll
stay you know what else wanted to say
our allies they could not believe we're
leaving i've been spending a lot of time
watching sky news and in britain saying
why didn't we try to stay ourselves
because we lost 400 guys um greg i know
you must have a lot to say i see a lot
of notes i was just waiting for you to
stop talking
did okay good uh i said this before i've
we've been far removed from this topic
for quite some while so it's a good
exercise to think about it before you
have an opinion assigned to yourself i'm
not going to refuse to get very very
upset about this again going back my
opinion has been in suspended animation
for possibly seven or eight years we've
done more uh segments on the bachelor
than uh than um afghanistan the argument
isn't about leaving we want to leave
it's how it was done it was bots we can
all admit that but there is something
that's really galling is that there was
a simple equation that we were all
working on for 20 years solve for x what
is x what happens when you leave i
cannot believe with all these experts
and all these commanders and all these
really really bright people we couldn't
foresee this 20 years we couldn't
prepare for this if you followed that
equation solve for that one solution we
probably would have killed more taliban
we would have been murdered we didn't
wage a war we were babysitting we didn't
wage a war we were trying to keep the
peace and i think that's where we are
now um so i'm i sound cynical and i'm
skeptical but i'm a little pissed off
that everybody assumed that it was going
to collapse you listen to people people
are saying you know i didn't think it
would collapse as quickly as it did but
it did it's like so wait everybody knew
that it would collapse even after all
this training and intelligence uh don't
get mad at people who are happy that
we're leaving don't call them quitters
or that somehow they're letting other
people down no they're just as disgusted
as everybody else about this we're
disgusted how this turned out but it's
not because
we want to leave that's bad we just we
just wanted this done correctly but by
the way we were too busy think about all
the stuff that we talked about on the
show we were too busy
talking about a commander who was uh
recommending an anti-racism book to his
uh his troops we had uh uh another um
what was that
name i can't remember the pc recruitment
ads right we were so we were so obsessed
with the virtue signaling uh debating
trans and military uh that we actually
stopped paying attention about the true
evil we sat here we obsessed over
january 6th
right we obsessed over this white
supremacy that's everywhere no we have
the taliban we have the terror it's
right there and now suddenly we're all
upset
where's your solution
uh i was been uh on this forever so i i
don't want to know i'm not that's why
i'm being i'm talking for myself brian
uh jessica go ahead
a couple of things
so i find with these speeches that i
always want to pick elements of it and
reorg the order
right and right maybe that just means
later in life i'd like to be a
speechwriter someone would hire me for
that but
there was a lot in it that i wanted to
hear including the buck stops with me
that's what i wanted but i wanted it
first
because that stops with me came after
the blaming of everyone else
right and that is i think what
democrats and supporters of the
president and his foreign policy
positions had really wanted to hear
which is i do take responsibility i
think it was the right choice but it
ultimately falls at my feet and yes i
might be the fourth president that has
overseen this conflict and i thought it
was a very smart line to say i'm not
going to pass this on to a fifth
president because 70 of the american
populist wants out of afghanistan
you always should say uh but do you
understand if there's a terror if the
terror attack at home and it came from
there would it be worth leaving i
i understand i think the idea is people
don't want to be subject to a terrorist
attack but that we should be able to
manage something like this after two
decades and getting to know the people
so well not even and
okay so there was one thing that he said
that stuck out to me which was our goal
was never nation building and that's
not true our goal was nation building or
at least in piecemeal it has dripped out
throughout this because we wanted to
build a thriving civil society and a
democracy so women like that poor afghan
reporter who definitely had the most
poignant moment of that briefing where
she said she put up her mask had her
home flag on it and she said where is my
president and she was talking about
president ghani who left yesterday and
we do we don't know where he is
and
we did and and i believed in it tried to
create a safe place for minorities in
afghanistan to be for women to thrive to
have a chance at having a business to
have a good job to not be subjugated to
the whims of their husbands etc and i i
think that we need to talk about that
more because what i've been looking at
what the kind of neocon establishment is
saying about this like the council on
foreign relations people who put out a
lot of ideas that i generally agree with
as a moderate democratic hawk and
they're saying this is not binary it's
not out or in it's how we get out and
nobody disagrees about the out it's just
the way that we get there and i didn't
hear details we heard 22 000 maybe
people can come here there are
definitely 22 000 afghanis who want to
come here uh how are you going to make
sure that our weapons do not end up the
taliban's weapons there was no guarantee
of that in that press conference and
that's the scariest thing not just in
terms of the air fleet but the weapons
on the ground scarier
the prisons the prisons containing isis
al qaeda taliban a wide open we left
them i don't know why uh the trump
administration agreed to let out five
thousand that's also something pretty
bad jake sullivan and tony blinken
talked a short time ago you've been busy
you just got off work this is the first
thing you've seen so let's watch
president did not think it was
inevitable that the taliban were going
to take control of afghanistan he
thought the afghan national security
forces could step up and fight because
we spent 20 years tens of billions of
dollars training them giving them the
best equipment giving them support of
u.s forces for 20 years we've seen that
that force has been unable to defend the
country and that has happened more
quickly than we anticipated all right uh
so they got the talking points down that
was the highlight so there was the
preview of the speech that we would take
in okay we we can analyze how we got
here and i think someone there's two
books coming out now that talks about
our missteps in afghanistan but dana
let's talk about now okay right now
there are i've never seen a situation
like that on the airport in my life
you're running as fast as you can on the
tarmac with this the biggest plane i've
ever seen and you have hundreds if not
thousands of afghans dying to get in
so their their answer is let's just shut
down the airport till we secure it i
guess until the seven thousand marines
arrive how do you solve this problem and
if the taliban starts moving on the
airport
what do we do then and the 2500 was too
many we got nine now well all good
questions um i
think in one
piece about the on the uh translator the
interpreters uh it wasn't that they want
to come to america they were promised
they could come to america it was if
you're willing to help us we will keep
you and your family safe and that that
was the reason that some of them are
desperately running right um but if you
one thing you haven't been i don't even
know if we have this but there's a
photograph you can see of inside that
plane and i think the american pilots
that were able to get that plane off the
ground i mean there were about 600
people on the plane they strapped people
to the floor they're not there weren't
enough seats i mean
in a way they did what they can but
again i go back to you shouldn't have to
do this kind of emergency if the
decision was made in april and on the
intelligence piece remember for months
what has been happening dod
about three months ago
leaked to the media that they had
offered to the white house the
capability to do a big airlift and the
white house said no thank you exactly
like that and then the intelligence
community kept leaking to the media
we're telling them that this is going to
be happening that's why they think
that's why they knew is because the
intelligence was telling them and not
only that they were telling us
so it and the american people shouldn't
have to again micromanage the process
the process should be managed by the
white house itself can i just give you a
little bit inside what they keep saying
is trump was going to pull out and they
said that the defense department was
rolling him the pentagon was not
listening to him nobody was they were
persuading him because i know the people
that were trying to persuade him in a
lot of cases they were upset about syria
he wanted to pull the way out he left
some there when he wanted to pull all
the way out of afghanistan he paused not
because they won it's because he
listened so greg i know you have you've
turned two more pages so what else did
the oh no i uh you asked what can be
done i've always felt that that what if
you watch the five i often overuse the
phrase the prison of two ideas here
again we're stuck in i don't get cable
at home sorry
i think we uh probably and biden miss an
opportunity to redefine the mission
if they're not gonna fight we don't
fight but we can redefine our role right
so we're terror control we're not in a
war we've we've talked about this before
we are terror control it's like pest
control you it's maintenance and it's
forever but not over the horizon yeah
the horizon doesn't work no no but if
you redefine it is that people
understand that it's an ongoing thing
it's like policing and you got to clean
it you got to clean out certain places
periodically that's how you look at this
someone needs to kind of make that idea
clear to everybody that we're not
interested in wars we don't i mean i
thought i agree with you i thought the
fifth president thing was super strong
but he was missing that next part which
is this is what we do about terror yeah
and i think well he gave in that entire
speech he said let's talk about how we
got here and he starts with the invasion
of afghanistan yeah yeah it's actually
not it was not something called 911 that
was not the beginning and i realized
that was really i would have added that
line in there it's like well we're about
to have the anniversary the 20th century
you look at the um you know the families
who have spent 20 years without their
loved ones um also the veterans who have
spoke spoken very movingly uh over the
past few days the gold star widows
they are all sitting there going wait no
we actually remember
the whole phrase of never forget didn't
start
in october when there was an invasion of
afghanistan it start on september 11th
and dana they don't need never forget
they can't forget because
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else